sono stato e sarò sempre un rugbista
106 presenze in nazionale xi edizione
del sé nazioni e 5 coppe del mondo e
l'ho sempre fatto con divertimento e
dedizione
mi rendo conto che ho sempre vissuto per
lei e per quello che rappresenta ho
lottato per lei
lo ha cercata
sono andato a prendermela là dove pochi
sono arrivati
cercando i miei compagni e contano su di
loro per dare insieme il meglio di noi
oggi questa palla voglio passarla a voi
oggi il mio campo è ancora più grande e
dentro ci siete anche voi con tutto ciò
che sono e che faccio voglio portare le
persone che incontro a dare il meglio di
se stesse
passiamo all'azione
giochiamo insieme
andiamo a far la differenza
cosa ha fatto di me quello che sono
diventato come sono diventato quel mauro
bergamasco e soprattutto attraverso
quali processi e con l'aiuto di chi
queste sono domande che io mi pongo
spesso e forse lo siete fatti anche voi
qualche volta eccomi qui a 37 anni a
chiedermi cosa ha dato forma alla mia
vita buda dice che siamo figli di
infinite cause
e allora se questo fosse vero non ci
sarebbe bisogno di cercare il perché le
ragioni
allora io oggi non voglio cercare perché
voglio farmi delle domande e tra le
tutele domani mi vengono in mente forse
ma works è veramente divertito sei
veramente soddisfatto sì ho fatto tutto
quello che potevo l'ho fatto sempre al
massimo e soprattutto non mi sono mai
accontentato di essere presente quando
ho potuto ho fatto più di tutto per
essere un protagonista tra la domanda
successivo potrebbe essere potevi fare
di più ho iniziato a giocare a 5 anni e
ho finito l'ottobre scorso la mia quinta
coppa del mondo
potevo chiedere di più sinceramente
allora mi chiedo forse trovato uno dei
doni di doni ho avuto fortuna per la
fortuna sì io mio fratello siamo nati da
due genitori che hanno che ci sono sono
cresciuti nello spirito dello sport di
squadra prima parte ha giocato alla
guida sempre ha giocato anche in
nazionale
e quando ha smesso ha cominciato ad
allenare ea educare centinaia di ragazzi
e ragazze in un piccolo club della
provincia di padova
mia mamma invece giocava a basket un
pallone è tondo
e quando e quando ha smesso di giocare è
diventata la nostra mamma allora se io
rivolgo il nastro all'inizio di questo
nastro vedo mio padre avevo più o meno
cinque anni e mio padre tornava a casa
dal lavoro mi metteva dentro il sacco
dell'allenamento amici portava allora io
arrivavo avevo 5 anni e vedevo tutti
questi ragazzi era un under 11 che lui
allenava avevano tutti quanti 9 10 anni
quindi è ben più grandi di me
e questi correvano si placavano
spassavano la palla correvano io
piccolino cerca di stargli dietro
a 25 anni faceva una fatica bestia
insomma alla fine di allenamento
mio papà ci divideva i due squadrette e
dava la palla l'uno all'altro la naval
spesso ai più timidi perché ovviamente
per far rientrare nel gioco primo dopo
la dava a tutti e allora però meglio
l'aspettavano lì era unica l'aspettavo e
l'abbiamo aperto prima o poi ma
dall'asta parlano ma la darà
ero sempre lì e correvo l'apertura noi
dietro questa palla e lui ce l'ha in
mano e io sono li e rom e la passa non
me la passava mai
e quando dico mai è mai
ok proprio è mai passata allora nel
rugby non si protesta nel rugby si gioca
si pensa sempre a giocare è però un
giorno sono avevo 5 anni è la pazienza
ha un limite
allora un giorno papam e la destra palla
e lui mi guarda e mi dice poi la palla
va te la prendere nessuno ti regala mai
niente crisi sono rimasto bloccato
se mio papà che a casa se mia mamma mi
ha sempre seguito mi ha sempre visto
subito nella crescita
adesso mi dice ma te la prendere nessuno
ti regala mai niente
insomma quel momento lì avrei potuto
urlare a gridare e piangere sono i
capelli manipolare mio padre la faccina
d'angelo e papa possa vista palla e
invece per fortuna non so per quale
motivo questa cosa non è successa tempo
di svegliarsi dopo di una smorfia i miei
compagni il pallone mio padre erano
dalla parte opposta del campo allora la
mia testa
e poi di pensare alle mie gambe si
mettono in moto mi portano lì da quella
palla con la palla per andare a
conquistare e correndo capisco capisco
quello che voleva che io facessi lui
voleva che quella palla ma la conquista
ci dà solo allora mi stava dando una
direzione mi stava dando un obiettivo su
cui credere poi successivamente ho
capito anche che avevo imparato il
sacrificio se edificio inteso come
rendere sacro il gesto che sto facendo
sacro perché ha un senso sacro perché ha
una direzione e qualche volta questa
direzione diventa molto più grandi di
noi stessi una direzione per arrivare
all obiettivo allora se io riavvolgo il
nastro la mia vita più o meno degli
ultimi 15 anni la mia carriera
io ho scritto un diario prima di ogni
partita scriveva un diario per
concentrarmi alcuni ascoltano la musica
altri mi chiamano la fidanzata alcuni
gioco col telefonino altri leggono vabbè
io scrivevo estivo tutti quelli che
erano i miei dubbi
tutte le parti tecniche le informazioni
che diano di cui avevo bisogno
e cominciamo col chiedermi come sto
stamattina mi sono svegliato sto bene
fisicamente non ho dolori mi sento
pronto e poi come mi sentivo come mi
sento mentalmente sono preparato sono
energico una settimana mi è servita e
sono pronto ad affrontare la prossima
battaglia e poi mi chiedevo cosa faccio
oggi cosa posso fare oggi per dare il
mio meglio
e allora questa domanda mi ha seguito
fino a qui
allora mi chiedo come possa essere
veramente utile agli altri come posso
aiutarli allora sicuramente non sono
quello che inventa le teorie dello
spazio assolutamente no non sono quello
che vi inventare up del telefonino non
ne sono capace una cosa so so come lo
sport ha saputo crescere e so come le
cose alle persone
hanno fatto per aiutarmi a crescere
allora io questo riconoscendoli
facendomi la domanda come posso essere
veramente utile agli altri e continuando
a dare agli altri quello che io ho
ricevuto fino ad oggi che per me ha un
valore enorme e che mi ha fatto anche di
risultati importanti
riavvolgendo il nastro sette anni fa più
o meno con cinque amici cinque
professionisti
ho dato vita abbiamo dato vita ai campus
rugby mauro bergamasco a un campus che
porta il mio nome è un campus del quale
ogni anno per due settimane si
incontrano 200 ragazzi e ragazze con
l'obiettivo di crescere giocando è un
modello formativo è diventato un modello
formativo e allora l'unico concetto che
avevamo ben chiaro è un concetto su cui
eravamo allineati era chiaro è
ovviamente molto semplice era che i
bambini devono prima essere educati da
educatori che sappiano insegnare le
regole con amore e poi possono essere
allenati da allenatori cene voi col
destro è un po come è successo a me io
da piccolo sono stato educato mi ha
lasciato dei principi dagli educatori
poi sono cresciuto ho imparato quello
che mi hanno insegnato quello che mi è
piaciuto ho preso quello che volevo sono
cresciuto e poi io mi sono rotto renard
agli atti gli allenatori da tecnici
anche internazionali e vi assicuro che
alcuni erano anche atroci atroci perché
per loro bastava che io fossi una
macchina del risultato per la domenica
però questo poco importava perché quel
sorriso quello sguardo di amore e
passione io la voce ha interiorizzato
prima allora
riavvolgendo il nastro della mia vita
come quel quello sguardo di amore e
passione aiutato me mi ha aiutato a
passare alcuni momenti particolari della
mia vita voglio raccontarvi la storia di
un ragazzino chiameremo tommy oggi
ragazzino che ha partecipato ai neo
campus
è forse quello sguardo l'ha aiutato
anche a fare quel passo nella sua vita
tommy a 9 anni e arriva al primo giorno
nella prima edizione del mio campus tra
lo serviamo e ci balza all'occhio che
lui non è non riesce a rapportarci quei
suoi compagni e non riesce a fare
amicizia fa fatica a interagire con loro
invece se per i mezzi più di nostri e se
per i mezzi piedi e noi parliamo di cose
da adulti perché dobbiamo organizzare un
campus siamo abbiamo la responsabilità
di questo campus e lui è sempre lì poi
si mette anche i mezzi discorsi e parla
da adulto è impostato allora io vi ho
detto questo la tener d'occhio ci siamo
detti forse queste settimane qual
otteniamo un po d'occhio perché vediamo
come possiamo aiutarlo e lui è salita
del giorno dopo arriva la mattina del 7
il suo uno dei suoi accompagnatori
avventure del gruppo e mi disse mauro
tranquillo lo porto di nove mattina alla
stazione dome la stazione a fare cosa
siamo al campeggio è perché lui insomma
la madre ha avuto un lutto di una
dinamica e 6 e lui è l'unica persona che
può starle vicino allora mi ha detto
anche che michela che la responsabile
del settore formativo educativo è adatto
gli ha dato il benestare perché in
accordo con la madre io cado dalle
nuvole detto ma da dove viene questa
storia
allora chiedo a michela michela mi puoi
dire qualcosa di questa storia mi dice
guarda non ne so niente credo dal però
anch'io
allora di michele abbiamo abbiamo un
problema
abbiamo un problema serio io ci provo
ci provo allora mi metto lì il campo e
la giornata prosegue metodi e lo osservo
che lo osservo lo guardo e lo vedo lo
vedo soprattutto vedo e riconosco le sue
buone intenzioni prima delle buonissime
intenzioni di questo ragazzo tommy abbia
delle mission intenzione lui voleva
partecipare all'attività vivo essere
voleva essere visto voleva essere
insomma qualcuno del gruppo voleva
essere leader
però un leader strano leader che vuole
comandare orali forse ho capito che
erano che era il modo con cui lui voleva
realizzare
i suoni le sue buone intenzioni che
l'italia va il problema che si creava il
problema è che non ne va anche
antipatico ai suoi compagni
allora ho detto ci provo
era lo ha chiamato tommy vieni devi
darmi una mano
questa è la palla insomma dobbiamo
organizzare degli esercizi da a spiegare
domani per compagni dobbiamo fare lavori
provarle perché domani mi devi aiutare
devi essere mio assistente e lui si
impegna prende la responsabilità
lavoriamo spa ti chiamo dal giorno dopo
non ho più sentito parlare di dove
ripartire lui stava già e integrando in
quel contesto
allora tornando con il nastro della mia
vita è un po come successo a me quella
volta quando mio padre mi dice quella
palla ma te la prendere la mia testa non
ha avuto tempo di pensare dei miei amici
sono mosse per cercare quella palla per
conquistarla allora ho fatto la stessa
cosa con lui io e top o mosso le sue
gambe
ho usato le sue risorse che in quel
momento erano libere e le o incanalate
in quelle cose che lui conosceva già era
il movimento allora riavvolgendo ancora
il nastro della mia vita
e se devo darmi una risposta a cosa ha
dato veramente forma la mia vita
allora in quel momento vedo vedo quello
sguardo con lo sguardo di amore e
passione fatto da fatto da persone
appassionate appassionate che ha sia in
grado di dare regole con amore vedo le
testimonianze che io ho ricevuto che
grazie all integrità anche delle persone
che ho incontrato l'integrità nel senso
che erano quello che dicevano di essere
gli obiettivi e io mi sono dato gli
obiettivi accompagnato tutta la mia vita
insieme al voler ad aver voglia di
imparare e alla voglia di conoscere che
stati i miei driver per tutta quanta la
vita su cui io credo molto
e allora sedia volgo ancora là della mia
vita e voglio andare avanti perché io
voglio andare avanti voglio continuare a
dare tutto quello che io ho vissuto
a tutti i bambini o meglio allo spirito
di tutti quanti i bambini di tutte le
età che loro abbiano 5 10 15
forse trenta forse anche 60 perché come
dice philip roth non si è mai troppo
vecchi per farsi un infanzia felice
grazie è l'ultima
un'ultima cosa io tra qualche mese
diventano padre per la prima volta
all'ora
allora questa sarà probabilmente la mia
partita più impegnativa
anzi sicuramente sarà quella più
impegnativa e allora io delle volte
prego e spero di avere quella forza e
quell'integrità per crescere mio figlio
e avere anche la capacità di usare
quello sguardo quello sguardo di amore e
passione per insegnare le regole con
amore che mi ha fatto crescere grazie